or celebrity legal news kirsten dunst
has a restraining order against a French
guy who's stalking her his name is Jean
Christophe Bruegel through the voice I
am Jean Christophe prove all I am from
Dijon France and do you have any Grey
Poupon
he has written her dozen of letters one
in which he said he had sold his house
to afford a plane ticket to come and
meet her in the United States Saturday
he showed up at her house
he made his stalker but he's a man of
his word she freaked out she got a
restraining order against him while
anyone would want to stalk kirsten dunst
is just beyond me maybe he's a dentist
oh that would be my greatest job ever if
I could fix that [ __ ] up grille of
yours this is going this way and that
way I could make you a perfect take a
look at her grille next time you got a
chance yeah she adds as we say she has
summer teeth summer here summer here
summer here I think one comes out of her
head trail out here why won't someone
save you Peter Parker oh my god I like
that one second spider-man that week she
can get married Miriam she shows up in
her in her wedding dress at his doorway
and he [ __ ] web all over everything
nice and and put webbing all over and
May comes in Peter no Alec Baldwin in
the news this week alligator with great
power comes great responsibility
alec baldwin of course i was going to
talk to you people
[Laughter]
alec baldwin was thrown off an airliner
last week american airlines because he
wouldn't turn off his phone before
takeoff yes Kevin we understand one
webbing is much like jism
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]